[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
nous retrouver pour ce premier set 8
sport de l'année à 2019
le magazine est toujours consacrée comme
vous le savez à l'actualité sportive
dans le département c'est parti à pour
le sommaire football une compétition de
futsal était organisée ce samedi à
guyancourt avec les jeunes du club plus
de 200 enfants se sont affrontés dans
des matchs à cinq contre cinq et détail
dans ce magazine vous l'américain les
templiers d'elancourt reprennent le
championnat de deuxième division ce
samedi à domicile contre les pionniers
de touraine
quelles sont les ambitions du club cette
saison nous recevrons dans quelques
instants trois joueurs de l'équipe
agenda après une année 2010 8
exceptionnelle marquée par
l'organisation de la ryder cup 2010 neuf
devraient également être out très bon
cru pour le sport et binoy nous avons à
lister les événements pas absolument pas
manquer cette année
reportage à suivre l'actualité sportive
de la semaine c'est maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
on ouvre ce magazine par du football et
plus précisément du futsal un tournoi
était organisé par le club de guyancourt
avec plus de 200 jeunes de la structure
des images de mares il n aille à pishin
aux avantages de eghezée b jana le
ballon était à l'honneur à guyancourt
pour la vingtième année consécutive le
club local organisé ce samedi 5 janvier
son traditionnel tournoi de futsal au
gymnase de l'aviation
ça permet au club de fêter la nouvelle
année avec tous les plus jeunes du club
réunir tous les éducateurs et les
dirigeants au total au rendez vous a
attiré 230 joueurs du club de la
catégorie des moins de 6 ans à celle des
moins de 13 ans objectif les tester dans
des conditions inédites
là on fait qu'on recherche c'est surtout
le jeu d'abord de pouvoir jouer en salle
ce qu'on n'a pas on n'a jamais
l'occasion dans la dans l'année de de
participer orange gymnase et puis ça
nous permet aussi la dans le cadre de ce
tournoi de jouer avec différentes
catégories
pendant la journée de tournoi 5 contre
50 étaient organisées dans le gymnase
chaque équipe était composée de
footballeurs de catégorie d'âge
différentes
le but équilibrer le jeu et surtout
créer du lien entre les participants ça
me changeait de plus à se connaître
et de plus tard s'améliorer et et et de
et de participer avec des gens qu'on
connaît pas pour
c'est d'être avec des équipes pour tout
essayé et 2
le club de guyancourt organisera un
nouveau tournant en juin mais cette fois
ci sur une pelouse en extérieur une
information handball à présent le club
de montigny le bretonneux va enregistrer
une arrivée de taille dans ce mercato la
joueuse slovène and in algeri tchèque
vient de signer dans le club qui évolue
dans la poule 3 de nationale 2 la
joueuse de 34 ans est notamment passé
par le club professionnel de nîmes entre
2011 et 2016 où elle a été élu meilleur
arrière gauche du championnat de france
en 2014 est également international
slovène avec cette arrivée le club de
montigny le bretonneux espère terminer
dans le top 5 de sa poule
à la fin de la saison on ouvre
maintenant une page football américain
le club des templiers d'elancourt
retrouvent le chemin de la compétition
ce week end les élans courtois vont
affronter à domicile au complexe sportif
europe les pionniers de touraine pour le
compte de la première journée de
deuxième division pour nous parler de
cette reprise nous relevons sur ce
plateau les joueurs à david pradalier
nice soumaré alexander song
bonsoir nous sommes alors comment vous
sentez vous avant la reprise plutôt bien
plus tôt chez roman précédé marins ça
fait quand même six mois qu'on est con
en attendent justement de foire
rechausser les crampons
on a fini la saison du coup sûr une
petite touche amère contre les corsaires
donc forcément on attend que ça de
recommencer d'aller d'aller en découdre
assez rapidement avec avec les équipes
de notre poule
alexander vous anime à vis du même avis
il faut qu'on commence au plus tôt c'est
à dire que moi l'année dernière j'étais
dans un autre club ou flash de la
courneuve et maintenant je reviens dans
mon
on va dire donc le familial est
l'objectif il n'est pas cette année
l'objectif et l'année prochaine c'est de
rehausser de est dans le top classement
en élite donc cette année c'est une
étape
yanis la préparation était comment du
même avis on a une bonne préparation
physique
donc on a eu un mois consacré seulement
pour le renforcement cardio et ensuite
on est parti sur un entraînement bas
spécialement faux bonds américains donc
la force qu'on a cette année c'est qu'on
a conservé notre groupe solide de
l'année dernière et en plus de ça on a
des joueurs qui sont assez importants
comme alexander song qui reviennent dans
notre effectif
comment vous sentez vous ce match du
coup comment vous sentez ce match ce
week-end il va falloir vite marqué les
esprits en tout cas pour ma part je
pense que tu vas falloir vite envoyé un
message à toutes les équipes de la poule
g pas commencer à dire quand on va
dérouler assez facilement mais je suis
assez confiant au vu de l'effectif qu'on
a des jeunes qui sont montés comme comme
alexander c'est le retour d'alexander
des des jeunes qui tiendront qui
tiendront le poste de cuves et donc non
je suis plutôt confiant sur ce début de
championnat
seddiki que vous connaissez bien les
pionniers de touraine on les a vu
l'année dernière
donc c'est une équipe qui nous a posé
quelques problèmes sur les deux
dernières saisons et c'est surtout des
joueurs qui étaient aux caïmans du monde
soit sur la saison précédente et qui ont
rejoint fait l'effectif de tours c'est
une équipe dont il faudra se méfier
alexander franchement très honnêtement
je pense que cette année il ya aucune
équipe dans la contre laquelle on
devrait se méfier c'est à dire que on
est à un niveau on peut pas se permettre
de considérer les gens contre qui on va
jouer contre des adversaires
on doit vraiment déroulé sur tous nos
matches c'est à dire qu'on a marqué les
esprits chaque score doit être important
notre objectif c'est l'année prochaine
c'est de montrer qu'on a le niveau élite
et non pas un niveau de deuxième
division et quels seront les recettes du
coup pour remporter la victoire ce
samedi
samedi ça va être la discipline donc on
a le niveau on sait on a l'effectif on a
les joues pour on a travaillé à
l'entraînement maintenant affaire
conçois qu'on reste discipliné et
comprennent notre défaite contre les
cancers les derniers
en demi-finale où l'ont mené à bien le
score en première mi temps et on s'est
fait remonter en deuxième comme le sont
et on va en prendre en hérite pour le
match de samedi
vous êtes d'accord et qu'ils aillent à
nice cannes et c'est surtout comme
alexander la di amoin of lors qu'on se
met aussi à notre niveau réel qui est le
niveau de la première division est
clairement de montrer à tout le monde
qu'on n'a pas notre place en deuxième
alors là vous commencez le championnat à
domicile
l'objectif c'est vraiment de rester
invaincu à domicile de faire 2 du
complexe europe une forteresse
totalement de rester invaincu non
seulement à domicile mais en restant
invaincu toute la saison alexander la
même chose de prendre le moins de points
possible je ne connais pas en fait
l'effectif on dire la force offensive
qu'ils ont mais en tout cas je connais
notre force défensive et ce serait sur
la saison de prendre un minimum de
points et je ne considère considéré
comme une défaite le simple fait qu'il
marque contre alexander qu'est ce qui
vous a séduit dans l'idée de revenir au
temps qui en fait ça a été plus mou au
niveau de la défaite de l'année dernière
c'est à dire que moi je voulais
reprendre avec ce groupe en première
division et j'étais présent sur la
tribune quand j'ai regardé le match de
la demi finale qu'ils ont joué au
complet corsaires et ça m'a affecté
énormément en fait l'effet de les voir
se faire remonter alors qu'ils avaient
parfaitement le niveau pour monter et
c'est quelque chose que moi j'arrive pas
à tolérer en fait un bon niveau donc moi
je suis revenu pour donner le moins
d'expérience et faire en sorte que les
choses reviennent là où elles doivent
être c'est à dire qu'on doit revenir au
niveau qu'on en a toujours eu et que
parfois on a un potentiel qui a été
limité à cause de certaines mentalités
et là je pense que cette année il ya des
là des mentalités ont changé il ya des
nouveaux qui ont été débloqués donc il
ya aucun problème cette année pour que
vraiment on déroule pour qu'on puisse
montrer notre jeu et que les joueurs qui
ont besoin en fait de montrer tout leur
potentiel pourront faire cette année que
les dirigeants vous ont rencontré avant
ce match est important de début de
saison qu'est ce qui vous en dis
dirigeants le dirigeant oui président on
a pu le rencontrer le président on en a
rencontré d'autres membres du bureau du
bureau et on est tous d'accord soit sur
la même chose on doit retourner en
mairie tout aujourd'hui on doit
retrouver la première division
c'est vrai qu'on a nos jeunes qui sont
un très bon groupe de jeunes qui
évoluent très bien depuis trois ans et
qu'on fait évoluer sur le groupe sur le
groupe senior est forcément ces jeunes
lisant quelques attentes et la première
attente c'est d'évoluer au plus haut
niveau et on veut les conserver chez
nous et vous avez ce sentiment que cette
année ça passe ou ça casse
moi pour moi oui il faut forcément que
conviennent si on veut conserver nos
joueurs nomades et on a des joueurs
comme alexander qui sont partis l'année
dernière parce qu'ils recherchaient
forcément aussi ce côté au niveau qu'on
n'avait plus depuis
depuis deux ans cette année on sait
qu'on a un bon gros comme on peut le
voir autour de la table trois
générations de templiers et c'est à
l'image en fait du groupe aujourd'hui on
a gagné ce qui a été formé au club
alexander qui a été formé au club moi je
suis peuvent rapporter des temps aux
templiers
mais voilà c'est ça l'image de
l'effectif qu'on aura cette année est
clairement c'est ça passe ou ça casse
depuis tout à l'heure on parle de la
formation des joueurs qui ont été formés
au temple idées en coin il y aura
également un importe sûrement us qui va
arriver dans les prochaines semaines est
ce que c'est important d'avoir ce set en
1 un port fort dans une équipe comme les
templiers alexandra ça reste toujours un
atout
cette agence est toujours positif
d'avoir quelqu'un d'une culture
américaine ou dans un autre pays mais
bon plus tôt américaine qui l'avenir
pour renforcer le groupe c'est à dire
qu' il va venir pour montrer
son niveau son expertise sur le football
américain ça fait toujours plaisir
également aux jeunes et également aux
anciens de voilà de voir qu'il ya une
force supplémentaire qui va être ajouté
maintenant sur cette année américains
ont pas je pense que on a aucun souci
pour lui c'est quand même plus pour
terminer premier mais toujours un plus
c'est toujours un plus et ça fait
toujours du bien ça peut reposer sur une
personne
on va terminer cet entretien par un
petit pronostic pour ce week-end bon
entendeur a donné le sien plus ou moins
tout à l'heure un petit pronostique une
victoire des templiers ce légal moi je
dirais une victoire des templiers avec
20 points d'écart on va points d'écart
alexander 50 points d'écart 50 points
d'écart les héros pour les lignes et de
touraine
si je m'occupe de la défense et devrait
y avoir zéro pour les je ne sais plus
comme un sapin comme yannis et on va
partir sur une jante est deux points des
cartes il prendre le moins de points
possible ça c'est en tout cas ils tort
pour tous les trois victoires de
pompiers merci à tous les trolls est
passé sur ce plateau on continuera
évidemment ou suivre tout au long de la
saison sur tv 78 on continue ce magazine
par du tir à l'arc une compétition salle
était organisé ce week-end par la
compagnie d'arc d'elancourt au complexe
sportif europe plus de 300 sportifs se
sont affrontés sur des tirs à 18 mètres
des images de mélanie poker mandat un
montage de sandrine fauteuil de la
précision du mental de la persévérance
la reprise n'a pas été simple pour les
archers ce dimanche 6 janvier à
elancourt
ils étaient plus de 300 courageux s est
inscrit pour participer
une recette qui fonctionne depuis 20 ans
alors ils viennent de un petit peu
partout au niveau de l'île de france et
du département
on a eu hier aussi des archers qui sont
venus belgique s'est cherché de belgique
on a des archers qui viennent de vendée
on a quelques archers qui viennent de
rôle
le rouen et les alentours surtout des
habitués mais voilà des gens qu'ils
connaissent maintenant au bout de la 20e
édition les locaux et qui savent qu'on a
des conditions de tir très agréable ici
ce concours en salle est qualificatif
pour le championnat de france les
concurrents se sont affrontés sur des
tiers à 18 mètres à un niveau
compétition on est comme tout comme dans
tout sport des fois des années on n'y a
pas plus performant que d'autres les
entraînements paye un peu plus mais on
est on est sur un département où il ya
beaucoup beaucoup darche et donc les
niveaux traversés et pour réussir leur
compétition certains ont leurs propres
techniques pour éviter une journée noire
c'est le cas de mathilde du club de tir
à l'arc de maurepas la sportifs
participent à son quatrième tournoi à
elancourt france est mauvais parce que
ça marche moins bien donc plutôt penser
à plein d'autres choses à rigoler et
puis un peu à une musique plutôt que de
penser vraiment aux compétitions parce
qu'après on regarde les points au kasaï
de calculer et ça marche pas comme une
grande partie de ses tireurs se
retrouveront dans quelques semaines pour
le championnat départemental une épreuve
qui se disputera au gymnase ou youri
gagarine de trappes les 26 et 27 janvier
on ouvre maintenant une page golf trois
mois après avoir mené l'europe à la
victoire à la ryder cup 2018 face aux
états unis au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le capitaine
européen thomas bjorn a honoré son pari
en se faisant tatouer la coupe et le
score de la 42e édition sur le
postérieur au regard des
les
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans la o2 thomas bjorn a beaucoup de
courage après le golf nous allons parler
d'un sport insolite qui débarque à saint
quentin en yvelines le fou de golf des
passionnés ont ouverte depuis à fin
octobre une section sur le territoire
pour nous parler de cette création nous
recevons sur ce plateau
clément rigaud le président il est
trésorier rémi heym ans bonsoir bonsoir
alors avant de parler de votre section
on va parler de foot golfe qu'est ce que
c'est alors que le football c'est assez
simple c'est fait à 99 % les règles du
golf c'est un sport hybride
c'est un sport il reste et ça c'était en
fait du coup les règles du golf sauf
qu'on joue avec nos pieds et un ballon
de foot avec des trous qu'ils font aux
53 cm de diamètre et du coup bas après
c'est le même principe il faut faire le
moins de coups pour pour avoir le
meilleur résultat possible à la fin des
18 trous mais bien synthétisé c'est ça
alors il ya combien de pratiquants en
france
je crois qu'on a à peu près à 5000 en ce
moment on espère sépare augmenter d'ici
les années à venir
c'est écrit il ya combien de temps en
fait ça a été créée il ya neuf ans aux
pays bas et ça fait quatre ans qu'ils en
chopent l'année en france et ça tend à
se développer en france
vous le sentez ouais je pense que ça
peut faire c'est un sport assez atypique
en soi et là il a toutes ses chances
comme les autres je dirais alors vous
étiez footballeur à l'origine qu'est ce
qui vous a poussé à aller vers le golfe
moi je faisais les deux choses du foot
et est du coup du golfe et puis bah en
fait j'ai mon cousin qui a découvert ce
sport en suisse
et du coup je me suis dit qu'il fallait
essayer et puis bah après une fois qu'on
essaye c'est compliqué d'arrêter
vous avez conseille quand même temps
j'ai commencé en 2014 même chose pour
vous non j'ai commencé l'année dernière
moi ça m'a blanchi directement sama sera
plus tout de suite donc partir de là je
me suis dit allez l'année prochaine je
tente ma chance
et alors premier résultat pour les
résultats ça va après il ya beaucoup il
ya quand même un assez haut niveau parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de pratiquants qui
fait beaucoup de personnes qui
pratiquent depuis très longtemps donc
il ya du boulot il faut forcément être
passionné de football et de golf pour
pratiquer à votre avis la plupart des
gens qui se mettent au football c'est
des anciens footballeurs qui en ont un
peu marre de chauffe eau de courir etc
du coup ils sont dit bon je vais prendre
ma retraite footballistique et puis je
me mette au fond du golfe et ses des
cadres en fait qu'ils sont super on ne
sort des parcours en jeu dans toute la
france même à l'europe et du coup ça
permet de voir des beaux paysages et
puis c'est vraiment très sympa une fois
qu'on a commencé et est ce que ça abîme
le terrain alors justement en fait on
joue avec des chansons des chaussures
stabilisé donc c'est des tout petits
crampons donc en face et s'équivaut
chaussures de golf ont du coup ça va kim
pas du tout les boeufs
alors pourquoi vous avez décidé de
lancer cette section est ici à saint
quentin en yvelines
ban où déjà on est donnée de la région
depuis tout temps on est né ici donc on
se dit je te zinc la boue c'est ma
famille qui avait lancé le club est en
fait il y avait aucun club lensois 18
donc on s'est dit bon bah cette année il
faut qu'on danse faut qu'on se lance et
puis et puis voilà ça y est c'est parti
pour début mars le championnat ça
commence et puis on espère que ça se
passera très bien le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines c'est vraiment un
territoire de foot golf potentiel bah
oui oui ce qui a énormément il ya
énormément de golf mine de rien dans le
78 donc je pense qu'il ya à l'heure
actuelle pour la pratique du football
s'il y en a que deux si je dis pas de
bêtises mais on sait qu'il ya énormément
de golf dans la région du 78 donc
pourquoi pas avoir quelque chose
d'intéressant autour du 78 vous sentez
que les gens sont intéressés autour de
vous oui oui on a commencé un peu à
tâtonner à gauche à droite par rapport à
nos amis nos connaissances ou même des
mêmes des collègues et la plupart des
personnes qui sont venues avec nous
s'entraîner ou jouer pour le plaisir
qu'on avait fait une initiation l'année
dernière en juillet août à la
queue-lez-yvelines et ça avait beaucoup
plu au groupe de personnes qui étaient
venues et d'ailleurs certaines personnes
ont même décidé de signer avec nous
cette année
alors pour l'instant peut pratiquer
cette discipline sur le golf blue green
de saint-aubin dans l'essonne à la
limite on va dire des yvelines
est ce que cette discipline pourrait
pourrait arriver dans un autre golf ici
à saint quentin en yvelines
alors nous on essaie de huy de trouille
bas il ya deux gosses et 50 en un mot qu
on aimerait bien que ce soit possible
dans un dé de golf
bon après j'imagine qu'on nous cache
tout cela c'est qu'on velthuizen de
saint-quentin levin et le bol face à
lougres ils ouvrirent de la base de
loisirs voilà donc ce serait vraiment
bien si on pouvait y avoir un golf bas
étant donné qu'on essaie quand on y
goûte golf de la boisson pendant ce
serait parfait après on est on n'est pas
bloqué sur un endroit perdre précis
c'est le but c'est d'ouvrir le plus de
parcours possible mais après de
faciliter l'accès aux gens qui veulent
se lancer pour essayer mais qu'est-ce
qui peut peut-être freiné les golfs à
votre avis peut-être la non connaissance
du sport tout simplement parce que on
peut se dire que on entend football
football n'a peut-être pas forcément une
bonne image par rapport à d'autres
personnes
voilà ce que je pense que ça peut être
le point qui freinent qui peuvent
freiner certaines personnes un sujet là
pour les ouvertures
est ce que ça peut freiner également les
golfs ou au niveau du terrain peut être
vu que les trous sont plus gros après
c'est vrai que ceux qui connaissent pas
du tout le football c'est ils doivent
s'imaginer forcément que convoiter les
taxes etc
mais c'est complètement autre chose donc
en fait fourrer juste pouvoir leur
expliquer qu'ils nous laissent la chance
de leur expliquer et puis après une fois
qu'on leur explique qu'en général ça se
passe bien ces investissements aussi
peut-être pour pour les golfs
c'est un aboutissement ouais c'est en
gros pour 18 trous c'est environ 2000
euros mais après si on fait dès qu'une
fille à 20 25 euros c'est quand même
rentabiliser assez rapidement en
longueur et le parcours est créé sur le
golf existant où il est créé à côté
alors que le temps en général on démarre
des départs du golfe et après en fait
les trous sont en gros à une dizaine
quinzaine de mètres des greens pour pas
justement abîmer les greens pour les
golfeurs à votre avis vous pensez que
que les golfs de nombreux golfs illinois
vont vous suivre dans les prochaines
années
je peux pas me prononcer là dessus mais
oui je l'espère du moins on espère après
c'est le tout c'est de les golfs
prennent conscience que c'est par on
abîme beaucoup moins le terrain qu'un
qu'un golfeur je sais pas si vous
pratiquez un peu bof
le golfeur peut être amené à faire des
trous dans le sol
chose que nous avec un ballon et être
notre pied on ne peut pas faire donc
déjà un cas ce niveau là ça peut
peut-être joué en hauteur notre faveur
vous avez contacté ses golfs de 50 ans
du mit alors en fait j'ai envoyé un mail
pour l'instant au directeur du golf qui
j'ai pas eu de réponse quand un an après
j'ai rendez vous avec les personnes de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines pour justement qui eux ont des
contacts directement avec eux et après
on espère que on aura une réponse
positive dans les quelques mois qui
arrivent dans la passion comment on fait
pour vous rejoindre
commence alors c'est assez simple on a
une page facebook donc ça s'appelle
savatan ligue de football flf
donc le mieux c'est de nous contacter
directement sur facebook
et puis après pour quand on a des
initiations mais sur notre page et puis
après ceux qui veulent l'argent mais
c'est avec plaisir au niveau du matériel
dernière question là c'est vraiment ma
delun question au niveau du matériel en
a besoin de quoi pour autant se lancer
des chaussures un ballon et un bermuda
si de préférence pour chaussettes hautes
et chaussettes hautes
il y avait une tenue quand même assez
élégante oui en fait c'est ça reste en
haut c'est un peu les tenues du golfe
des années 60 en fait c'est du jacquard
bon après c'est pas obligatoirement du
jacquard le truc typîque du football
c'est ça c'est le jacquard mais après
des chaussettes vote a permis d'ailleurs
paulo ça suffira pour commencer qu'est
ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter pour 2019
et bien un bon championnat et puis qu'on
arrive à trouver un golf et que tout
gosse se développe de plus en plus merci
à tous d'être passé sur ce plateau on
l'espère seul et foot golfeur c'est
comme ça qu'on les appelle golfeurs sont
de plus en plus nombreux dans les
yvelines on passe maintenant à notre
page agenda
[Musique]
pour ouvrir cette page agenda je vous
propose un tour d'horizon des événements
sportifs qui vont étudier l'année 2019
dans les yvelines après une année
exceptionnelle marquée par
l'organisation de la ryder cup à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 2019 devrait
également être un très bon cru
regardez 2019 sera placée sous le signe
du sport dans les yvelines l'année
débutera par un combat de boxe le 16
février prochain et en courtois marvin
petit va tenter de remporter un titre
européen dans la catégorie des poids
légers face aux belges de francesco pas
terreur bon bah ouais que j'attends
depuis depuis pas déjà regardé depuis
tout jeune quoi que j'aurais jamais
urgent que jamais cru attendre quoi dans
ce combat oui là qui me disent favori il
y en a qui me disent que j'avais un
combat difficile dure
après moi je sais qu'il est un combat tu
vas être physique physique puis
physiquement je serai là j'ai toujours
une physique
je ne ferai rien et je pense que je vais
lui faire très très mal
2019 par créa également le retour du
jumping de versailles après avoir annulé
l'édition 2018 foot de dates disponibles
les organisateurs ont programmé ce
concours hippique de sauts d'obstacles
international du 26 au 28 avril en face
du château
autre retour après 20 ans d'absence les
championnats de france féminin par
équipes nationales pas de gymnastique
reviennent en ile de france
la compétition sera organisée au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
on attend mille quatre cents gymnastes
sur les trois jours qui seront
qui font la pétition et on espère
atteindre 5000 personnes
sur ces événements aux spectateurs à
quelques mètres du vélodrome nationale
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines accueillera le samedi 16 mars
l'eco trail de paris des milliers de
coureurs vont s'élancer depuis tra pour
parcourir 80 km jusqu'à la tour eiffel
on part sur la base de loisirs de saint
quentin et puis on part dans un une
espèce de chant qui est relativement
beau ce n'est pas évident pour les
filles donc faut faire faut rester
attentif aux trouver le bon rythme pas
se cramer trop vite
en golf l'open de france sera une
nouvelle fois organisé sur le golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
cette année le rendez vous ne sera pas
programmé fin juin mais du 17 au 20
octobre et devient l'avant dernier
tournoi de la saison en europe
l'open de france en juin a pu souffrir
par le passé d'une trop grande proximité
de tat avec roland garros où avec le
tour de france ou avec leur au mondial
de foot
donc on pense qu'en étant placés en
deuxième partie de saison là on a un
coup à jouer si on peut dire
il y aura enfin du cyclisme de haut
niveau sur le territoire pour la dixième
année consécutive le paris-nice et
lancera des yvelines le 10 mars
le parcours sera officiellement dévoilé
ce mercredi 9 janvier
toujours sur la route rambouillet sera
ville départ sur la 26e et dernière
étape du tour de france le dimanche 26
juillet plus de 40000 spectateurs sont
attendus pour l'événement enfin le
stadium de bmx de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines recevra deux
manches du circuit de coupe du monde et
de coupe de france les 8 et 10 juin
prochains
le calendrier 2010 9 et fixer les
yvelinois de demande maintenant à qu'à
vibrer il y aura également des matches
très attendus ce week-end en rugby dans
le championnat de fédérale 2 plaisir va
recevoir dans son stade gennevillois
pour le compte de la 13e journée
un match qui s'annonce serré les deux
équipes ne sont séparées que par cinq
petits points au classement victoire et
plaisir pourrait s'éloigner de la zone
de relégation
on continue par le championnat honneur
de rugby versailles premiers du
classement reçoit monter son dauphin
pour le choc de cette 10e journée en cas
de victoire les versailles invaincu
depuis le début de la saison prendraient
une sérieuse option sur la montée en
fédérale 3 si vous voulez les soutenir
la rencontre est programmée ce dimanche
à 15 heures au stade de porsche antennes
et on termine notre agenda du week-end
par la poule 2 du championnat honneur le
sky rugby recevra ce dimanche à 15h dans
son stade du bout des clots l'équipe de
melun combs
senard sixième du classement les saint
quentinois seront favoris de cette
rencontre face au dernier du championnat
en cas de victoire les hommes de thomas
payen pour est entré dans le top 5
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine d'ici
là passez une excellent une excellente
semaine sportive très belle soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]